all right also tonight the biden
presidency is going from well bad to
worse as inflation surges gas prices hit
one record after another stocks are
sinking and americans are suffering
under the cost of joe biden's failing
far left agenda
and joe biden himself he couldn't be
more checked out just look at your
screen
earlier today biden was spotted
literally you know jogging running to
marine one he couldn't get there quick
enough as he scurried out of washington
for yet another relaxing weekend at the
beaches of delaware
and even his wife jill had to grab him
by the arm and tell him quote we've
gotta go
watch
number three
i think we're gonna be in a position
where
jill biden playing the role of the
easter bunny now biden's blunders come
as his approval continues to hit one low
after another
because according to a new poll from
yougov
biden's disapproval it's at yet another
new high a whopping 56 percent of
americans disapprove
and get this more americans now say they
would support donald trump in a
potential 2024 rematch by a margin of
44-42
but if all that wasn't bad enough for
biden and the far-left democrats a new
report from the hill is exposing more
white house turmoil with several aides
reportedly tapped out the article says
and looking for the exits i mean can you
blame them having to constantly clean up
and walk back joe's remarks having to
defend one failed policy and blunder
after another
and having to work for a president who
frankly is in steep decline and seems to
be trying to bring down the country with
him
costs surging because of joe biden
recession fears growing because of joe
biden
and confidence in american leadership is
dwindling
because
of joe biden here for reaction former
white house chief of staff reince
priebus along with fox news contributor
joe concha thank you both for being here
right let me start with you you had a
boss who was famously unorthodox
but everyone knew where the buck stopped
who was making the calls
what do you make of what's happening for
staffers for the organization inside the
current biden white house
well i thanks for having me pete first
of all you're right i mean donald trump
was the chief of staff he was the coms
director the press secretary you know
that and we all know that but the one
thing that he did do
was that there were plenty of inputs he
listened to everyone's opinion and he
listened to people who believe the
opposite things about a particular issue
and he had
he had a lot of inputs and so i think
one of the things that you're seeing
from joe biden and this decision making
blunder after blunder is that he doesn't
have a lot of inputs which creates a
scenario for a lot of bad
decision-making and then what happens
there is that nothing's going well i
mean what joe biden has done is he
directly attacked the policies of donald
trump and those direct attacks whether
it be gas whether it be inflation or you
name it haven't worked he didn't listen
to the warnings from
his own economists about pumping the
economy full of cash um and so at the
end of the day you've got a staff that
is getting nowhere
they're
they're they're not winning on any
particular issues the democrat base is
not happy with the president he's at 20
approval of strong approval among
democrats whereas if you look at donald
trump
in in spite of a very vitriolic
political environment he was always at
90 95 percent strong approval within his
own party last thing
joe biden didn't do what he promised he
said he was going to look out for the
american worker and the american worker
is getting cremated every single day out
there across america
no doubt joe what is the communication
strategy so policy is one thing and
that's the most important thing then you
don't have to spin it if it's actually
working but if you're having to spin it
and you're staring at a binder and
you're giving late night interviews uh
and you're being pulled away from the
press pool uh by your wife what is what
is their approach
well the communication strategy pete is
craptastically patently horrible right
because for instance the president said
in an interview this week that
inflation is high all around the world
that we have a global problem and and
we're just a part of that global problem
and then you look at all the countries
that have lower inflation than we do
china for example has 2.1 percent
inflation we are at 8.6 we are four
times more than china right now and i
could go through all the countries from
saudi arabia to india to indonesia to
australia to italy that have lower
inflation than we do yet this president
thinks that we're stupid enough to think
that okay well everybody's having bad
inflation it's just something that's
happening globally and i really have
nothing to do with it so look if donald
trump runs and it's almost virtually
guaranteed that he will because you
don't hold rally after rally in the past
year if that isn't the plan he has some
pretty easy contrast to make if he stays
on message on inflation i'm fairly
certain that a businessman like trump
wouldn't say that the solution like
biden has is for lowering inflation is
spending trillions more you know just
just a hunch on that one that trumps
don't want to go to that route right
exactly on gas prices it's absolutely
certain that a president trump 2.0 or
ron desantis if he's the nominee or
basically any republican not named you
know kensinger or cheney would restart
the expansion of the keystone pipeline
the xl pipeline would open up drilling
in anwar and wouldn't reject these oil
leases in the gulf of mexico and the
alaska coast and on the u.s border if we
could even call that anymore wall
construction would be restarted remain
in mexico policy would be reinstated
look the bottom line is that joe biden
is currently polling at the lowest
numbers of any first term president in
polling history you're going to go all
the way back to truman to trump and he's
lower than that and david axelrod and
he's a former chief advisor to obama
biden in that administration said that
the prospect of a joe biden being closer
to his 90s than his 80s in the second
term is one that almost all americans
democrat republicans will not embrace in
any capacity that's where we are right
now pete
wright's real quick joe just laid it all
out if you're ron klain and the chief of
staff you've been in that seat what do
you do right now
uh you walk into the oval office and say
mr president it's not working out you're
not happy i'm not happy
let's find a replacement to start this
thing over because they need a reset you
know if you
if you took the sat today and guessed c
every single time you'd have a better
score than what joe biden his team has
done
that is an indictment hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else